cartes bancaires comptes courants crédit
à la consommation non seulement les
banques traditionnelles doivent se
méfiait des banques digital mais aussi
garder un oeil sur les gaffes qui lorgne
sur une part du gâteau bancaire bonjour
pascal de lima bonjour vous êtes
économiste et prof à sciences po est ce
que c'est de la science fiction parce
qu'en 2050 on peut imaginer que sa
banque s'appelle google alors on a mis
50 on pourra imaginer certes mais faut
quand même bien comprendre pour se
projeter ce qui se passe aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui très clairement les gars
femmes ne sont pas dans les crédits
immobiliers ni dans les crédits à la
consommation par an que sorin pas encore
sauf aux états unis et encore elles sont
pas réglementées si vous voulez donc en
europe aujourd'hui on n'est que sur du
paiement sans contact mobile maintenant
ce qui est source d'inquiétude pour les
banques traditionnelles c'est qu'elles
ont une des ambitions complètement folle
en fait et puis elles ont une trésorerie
considérables et donc cette trésorerie
et leurs ambitions faut savoir que
alphabet la la la société mère de google
depuis 2000 a lancé plus de 43 projets
dans le domaine du duc de l'octroi de
crédits dans le domaine de la
cybersécurité bref c'est des projets
tous les jours avec des films tech et
donc ça fait craindre quand même une
arrivée progressive des gars femmes sur
les marchés bancaires traditionnels déjà
vu revenir sur les marchés américains on
voit beaucoup de choses aucun gaffe à ne
fait du crédit pour le prêt immobilier
pour le moment mais c'est inéluctable
ils ont avancé leurs pions vous l'avais
dit dans la carte de crédit le crédit à
la conso aux états unis aux états aux
états unis il ya apple paix pour les
paiements mais il ya aussi des crédits
comment dire la possibilité d'étaler les
paiements sur les produits sur les
produits apple il y à il y as où les
défis financement locatif également il
faut faut-il le rappeler qu'apple en
france fait avec le cic notamment des
services de location du leasing comme on
dit a donc il ya déjà quand même une
première pénétration sur les marchés
financiers en france on est qu'aux
balbutiements on n'est qu'au début c'est
pas sur des crédits conso c'est pas sur
des crédits immobiliers ou là certaines
et aux banques mènent 26 et révolution
beaucoup plus menaçante mais on commence
à gratter un peu amazon qui accorde des
petits prêts aux pme françaises c'est le
début de quelque chose c'est une attaque
frontale ça aussi alors c'est une
attaque frontale s'est pas encore
réglementé c'est à dire que c'est il
faut faire attention il faut quand même
prévenir tout le monde que il faut être
prudent il faut savoir qu amazon aux
etats unis c'est encore plus fort qu'en
europe puisque amazon aux états unis
fait des crédits d'exploitation aux
pme/tpe 1 on a encore un an n'a encore
avancé un coût d'un coup si vous voulez
bon voilà mais globalement aujourd'hui
il faut bien le rappeler ça reste encore
un prestataire de services de paiement
qui travaillent qui travaillent avec des
banques qui ne sont pas là est ce que
dans le fond les gaffes ivl où ils ne
veulent pas être banquier ce que est ce
que les services bancaires c'est une
espèce de relais de croissance pour eux
ou est-ce que ça sert leur modèle parce
que c'est une façon d'avoir plus
d'informations sur les clients
utilisateurs que nous sommes oui il ya
deux sujets il ya la question du fait
que les gars femmes gèrent énormément de
données sur les clients lorsque vous
faites un paiement via apple paix via
google paie en fait vous fournissez des
données considérable via apple ouaddou
fournissez des données considérables
vous allez au restaurant vous payer via
apple welsh vous fournissez des données
considérables donc ça leur confère un
avantage si vous voulez par rapport aux
banques parce qu'on dit que les banques
détiennent deux cents en données
moralité en deux ans les gars femmes
peuvent détenir le même nombre de
données donc c'est un avantage dont un
est une menace pour les banques c'est
pas une menace imminente pour nos
banques européennes c'est pas une menace
imminente mais cependant du fait de
cette gestion de données du fait de ce
qu'on observe aux etats unis du fait de
leurs ambitions les connaît leur
puissance finances et de leur puissance
financière il y a réellement une menace
faut-il comparer la capitalisation quand
même des dégâts femmes 5300 milliards
c'est pratiquement voilà le pib c'est
plus que le pib des pays-bas si vous
voulez hein donc c'est quand même
quelque chose d'assez et là c'est
considérable pour l'instant regard des
partenariats entre les banques
américaines on situe aux états unis et
les gaffes à apple a passé un accord
avec avec goldman sachs google avec
citigroup donc pour le moment on n'est
pas au stade de la guerre mais du
partenariat on est au stade du
partenariat parce qu'il faut bien
comprendre que les gars femme ça reste
quand même de la technologie mais en
face il ya le métier est aujourd'hui et
d'ailleurs je pense déjà à très court
terme le métier ça reste encore dans la
banque
on peut pas mener page ou gère pas des
crédits ont géré pas le risque bancaire
du jour au lendemain avec uniquement des
applications ce que pour résumer
finalement ce sont des applications
c'est de la technologie par contre il y
à des partenariats qui commence à se
tisser entre eux gars femmes et banque
entre bandes et des haubans qui
conçoivent les produits qu'ils
consomment les produits qui font la
stratégie qui a faim vous diront
peut-être se passer des banques et avoir
la relation en direct avec le client
c'est ça l'idée c'est de pouvoir avoir
la relation directe ceci dit encore un
je pense à laps de temps important parce
qu'elle a réglementé sur wii qui est
extrêmement contraignantes pour les
banques il a pour les banques et dont on
n'aura pas les gaffes à quand les gars
femmes on voit très bien ce qui se passe
aux etats-unis avec facebook avec un
histoire cambridge analytique arr etc
microsoft et abus de position dominante
on voit très bien on voit très bien que
surtout on ne voit pas d autorité
tutelle agrémenter les gars femmes dans
les services financiers comme le font
les banques du jour au lendemain il va
falloir attendre encore un peu mais
voilà dans 50 ans quand on parle du
monde du tout techno et du
transhumanisme liées aux métiers de
demain et aux innovations on se demande
pourquoi finalement les gars femme ne
nierai pas beaucoup plus loin dans quoi
je dirais pesant tour sur 50 ans oui sur
sa quarante ans oui sur après demain non
par contre attention et là c'est ce sont
des ses plus des mammouths un peu lent
technologique mais ce sont des hyènes
extrêmement ravi ce sont les néo banques
parce que la n 20 6 est révolu par
contre sont déjà des établissements de
crédit voilà merci beaucoup en tout cas
pas celle du rubin économiste et
professeur à sciences po
[Musique]